[Musique]
e
madame rien maréchal j'ai 56 ans j'ai
trois enfants
dans la vie je suis famille d'accueil
depuis 22 ans
j'accueille trois malades un
hémiplégique tétraplégique et les
malades c'est donald kohn près mon
mariage que j'ai travaillé avec mon mari
bain pendant 12 13 ans à faire des
samoussas les traditions créoles et tout
ça ça me permet pas d'être avec mes
enfants que du présent n'était pas
présent avec mes enfants
moi je cherche quelque chose pour que
moi et puis c'est pas nuit avec mes
enfants ils le disent eux
pourquoi pas les personnes âgées pour
moi si c'est ma vocation à l'âge de
saison v et des mama mama tente qu'elle
était malade elle avait dessus a eu une
suite de couches et puis ben j'allais
chez elle point de lui donner son bain
fait à le manger et puis nettoyer sa
maison
ah oui c'est très important de soutien
de mon mari surtout lui bain et on est
complémentaires tous les deux dit qu'en
pharmacie soit en ville il est là c'est
lui qui s'occupe de 2 et puis même dans
les pôles et coup c'est tout et pour
tout il faut il faut quand même avoir un
soutien familial même les enfants
[Musique]
qu'ont en fin de vie chez vous pendant 6
mois ou un an ou deux on lit on est
fatigué on est fatigué et puis on a
envie de faire le deuil aussi un peu mou
c'est notre famille c'est mon grand père
mon grand père ma grand mère et mon
frère parce que parfois il est jeune
aussi au moins de l'assedic pour pouvoir
me reposer un petit peu pendant six mois
et puis à peu reprendre le travail après
mamie parce qu'on peut travailler tout
de suite n'est pas fort n'est pas prêt
on est trop fatigué pour reprendre le
dessus
moi ce qui aide à moi c'est la fois que
moi et n'a pour aider les autres aussi
et les personnes et puis donnant une
place peu habité aussi deux est une
famille aussi parce que la république
tout seul beaucoup de patience beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de patience très à l
écoute ce que a besoin attentionnée
avant la disponibilité possible parce
que ce n'est pas disponible pour
participer à ce travail là car beaucoup
d'amour beaucoup beaucoup dans la poche
pour donner